hi in this video we are going to talk
about the concept behind diabetes it is
also known as extravasation of blood
cells now diabetes is is the passage of
blood cells through the intact capillary
wall and this process is known as
diabetes is typically neutrophils or
monocytes they undergo diabetes in order
to understand the concept behind the
hypothesis and context behind this
concept we need to understand when does
it occur where does it occur and how
does it order but before that hit the
subscribe button because I provide lot
of these kind of videos which are super
helpful for biology students now let's
bring out a context and this is your
skin and let's say you are pricked by a
rusty nail and along with the rusty nail
there are a lot of pathogens such as
bacteria and other harmful pathogens
enter your body right into your area
under the skin so under the skin which
is just like a physical barrier there
are many patrolling police officer which
are macrophages or dendritic cells so
they would immediately notice that
somebody invaded and they would try to
go there and try to find the situation
for example the macrophage would engulf
the pathogen and try to break down the
pathogen and display some of these
pathogenic antigens on the top of class
2 MHC molecules as macrophages or
professional antigen presenters so after
detecting this they would also secrete
some alarming signals these are called
cytokines which would attract other
macrophages to the nearby region or
other patrolling police officer to the
nearby region such that together they
can fight the situation in a bad better
manner this is like calling for a backup
ok some of them would also go to the
nearby lymph node and thereby activating
other components of the immune system
now they secrete cytokines this cytokine
has
to do with other blood type blood cell
types such as neutrophil so let's say
this is a blood capillary which is
situated just under the skin and we
would see what changes happen at the
neutrophil in response to that pathogen
innovation and this change is actually
conveyed by the signals secreted by
these antigen presenting cells now out
of many things first of all the
neutrophils which are rolling across the
blood capillary they would encounter a
selective now selecting is basically
expressed by capillary endothelial cells
which are activated or activated by any
kind of cytokines such as inflammatory
cytokines now in response to that our
neutrophil would express a glycoprotein
known as s legs which is a Sai lytic
glycoprotein and that kind of interacts
with the e selecting and this molecular
interaction slows down the rolling
process of this neutrophil furthermore
this neutrophil would Express
LF a one or leukocyte factor one which
would interact with the surface
glycoprotein known as I cam which is in
turn present in the endothelial cells
now these interaction in a combined
fashion would ensure that neutrophil
does not roll anymore it becomes
stagnant to a particular location so the
neutrophil would halt at that particular
location now there are sudden changes
happening to the capillary wall as well
in this particular case when there is no
sign of inflammation the capillary wall
is intact and there is almost no gap
between these two capillary endothelial
cells but when there is inflammatory
cytokine secretion this really affects
the capillary endothelial cells and the
tightness of packing of these capillary
endothelial cells are altered now you
can see there are a lot of gap in
between that and this neutrophils would
undergo cytoskeleton rearrangements such
that they can squeeze their way through
out of these capillary and can enter the
tissue space so they would really try to
squeeze through their way and once they
managed to go out of the blood vessel
they would go and reach the tissue space
this process by which they can
first rolls slowly get stagnant to a
particular location and followed by that
using cytoskeletal rearrangement signals
they can move out of the blood vessel is
known as their penises or otherwise
popularly known as neutrophil
extravasation now the question is once
the neutrophil is out of this blood
vessel what would happen to it now the
neutrophil would experience several
signals which are actually cytokine or
chemokines so chemokines are working
like attractions which would attract
these neutrophil and allow it to migrate
along its gradient now the neutrophil
would reach the site of infection when
there are lot of pathogens now the
neutrophil would provide a further back
up to our patrolling police officers
which are like macrophages and the
dendritic cells now these are the
pathogens which are now to be
encountered by the neutrophils the
neutrophils try to engulf the pathogen
and after involving the pathogen they
can neutralize the pathogen and actually
there are many other ways by which
neutrophil can help the immune system to
fight against a particular pathogenic
invasion in order to know more about
neutrophil and a net immunity you have
to watch my other videos
but for now if you like this video give
it a thumbs up don't forget to Like
share and subscribe thank you and do let
me know in the comment how do you like
my videos your positive feedback will
give me so much motivation to make more
such videos thank you